Europe has been very successful for a
number of reasons one there was a
certain collective reckoning after World
War two and the presence of very
enlightened statesmen and the support of
the United States all coming together at
around the same time and helping to
kick-start a process a very mild and
primarily economic European integration
among a few core countries what that
grew into into the European Union of
today is a remarkable success story
there was always a or has been a debate
about whether Europe should be widening
or deepening and the fact is that Europe
has done both it has grown broader and
since 1991 it has grown by on average
one country per year it was 16 12 and 16
it's all the way up to 27 and may soon
be 30 member states so it's grown
broader it's also growing deeper the
density and depth of institutions that
exist in Brussels Luxembourg Strasbourg
and elsewhere is absolutely unbelievable
the common currency and all of these
sorts of developments parliamentary wise
judicially and so forth the existence of
the European Commission these things
were not we're not it wasn't it wasn't
self-evident that these institutions
would have would have grown the way they
did in the 1950s but they have so it's
been a remarkable success story even if
it were to stop today Europe has common
military forces like a small Rapid
Reaction Force it has 10 or so
peacekeeping missions active right now
from Lebanon to the Congo it has armies
of course many it has more troops under
arms than America does but not
necessarily one large common army it
doesn't have to it doesn't have to
define itself by our terms European
armies can work together more and more
as they are doing without ever forming
one unified army under one flag so I'm
less concerned with whether or not they
form one army then that they simply put
their troops on the ground and their
money where their their sort of money
where the mouth is on a variety of
issues
that's one reason and one primary reason
why Europe is most definitely a
superpower is that first of all
economics is a large lot more important
today in calculating an empires or
superpowers level of power than it was
in the past and when it comes to
economic size Europe is larger than the
United States the European Union is the
largest economy in the entire world it
is significantly larger than that of the
United States it has a larger population
as well their product standard safety
standards and so technical standards are
far higher than that of the United
States as well so if you want to sell if
you are a manufacturer in China or
Malaysia or whatever you want to sell a
product in the world and you want to
streamline and make it one way well you
have to adapt to the European standard
not the American standard so yes
absolutely their products obviously are
superior when it comes to automobiles
engineering and all that kind of thing
they don't have this sort of IT output
that Silicon Valley has but they have a
number of competitors and they
incorporate that technology quickly and
spread it through their market as well
but that's just one aspect of economic
power the other aspects also involved
their own externally directed investment
they export more capital around the
world than we do
Europeans invest more money in China
than America does Europeans give way
more foreign foreign assistance and
development assistance then America does
Japan ranks I think second to Europe and
then comes the United States in terms of
for investment so those are some other
metrics by which Europe is economically
more powerful and more important than
the United States is around the world
well there are certain European
countries that are experiencing
population decline of course in Italy
and Germany are among them and by
decline one can also just mean as a sort
of plateau of the population but because
you're up as a union continues to grow
its population as a whole continues to
grow if by European population decline
you mean the few Western European
countries that have defined Europe to
this day and who culturally we might
prefer to think of as European then yes
that absolute number may be declining
but if by European you mean a large
number of new peoples migrating and
becoming part or incorporated into the
European Empire then the European
population is 450 million which is 150
million larger than the United States
so demographically it's quite healthy
and you have to think about young
populations like like Turkey and Ukraine
50 million in Ukraine and 70 80 million
in Turkey that have Arab like
demographic profiles very young
populations of course we don't think of
them as European but they think of
themselves as European and they are
becoming Europe